they wrote against each other in
Unforgiven they ride together tonight
gene Hackman and Morgan Freeman
taking pictures gets easier every year
any amateur can do photography and sharp
colors and perfect pokers and there's no
need to know how the equipment does it
that's the science of shooting pictures
the art of it is better left to our
cinematographers for those artists film
is their canvas cameras their brushes
and lenses their eyes they mix vision
with sensitivity to paint poetry that
stirs our hearts and lingers in our
minds the poets nominated for Best
Cinematography are Stephen H Boram ha ha
ha Tony Pierce Roberts for Howards End
ho bear pres for the lover filly who
slow for a river runs through it Jack in
green for Unforgiven and the Oscar goes
to
Philippe Rousseau or River run through
it
well this is the first thing I ever
caught in a river I would like to to
thank mr. mr. Bradford for we took a
little Frenchman to film this very
American story and it gave me the chance
to have my tiny tiny little little
moment and chair of the great American
culture and I would like to thank all
the cast and crew of River for not only
a wonderful work but also for a the most
marvelous welcome in this country thank
you to all of you thank you very much